vous êtes français
nous allons la voir dans quelques
instants je disais que cette interview
était enregistrée hier après midi de
même que le clip qui suit cette
interview céline dion tout de suite
céline dion votre première chanson
c'était comme dans un rêve je crois ce
n'était qu'un n'était qu'un oui mais ça
c'est mon premier 45 tours québécois
savent pas mais c'est toujours un rêve
vous avez 19 ans je crois et vous êtes
toujours dans un rêve bah oui et non
parce que bon c'est un rêve depuis
toujours de chanter je connais juste la
musique et mes frères et soeurs font de
la musique aussi chantent et jouent des
instruments musée alors on voit pas
souvent en france c'est parce que vous
êtes très occupé là bas au québec on ne
voit pas souvent un franc j'essaie de
venir quand même assez régulièrement je
passe bon à peu près là en gros simon au
québec six mois en france j'essaie de
venir le plus souvent passé mais au
québec vous chanter sur scène vous êtes
accompagné par des musiciens ou fait de
la scène alors qu'en france on n'a pas
eu le plaisir encore de vous voir sur
scène à écouter ça fait six ans que ce
que je chante déjà j'ai commencé ma
carrière chez nous avant de venir en
france
et puis j'ai quand même vu de 30 cm les
huiles en jeu chez nous donc je peux me
permettre maintenant avec autant de
répertoire de faire de la scène
ici j'ai quelques 45 tours mais je crois
que j'ai passés matériel encore mais
j'aimerais ça j'ai quand même fait
l'olympia pendant six semaines tous les
soirs avec patrick sébastien
ça a été un grand honneur j'espère
pouvoir leur et vous vous préparez bien
pour la sienne en tout cas parce que je
crois savoir où vous prenez des cours de
danse
ben oui je prends des cours de danse je
prends des cours de chant j'ai arrêté
l'école mais j'étais toujours pour mon
métier parce que j'ai envie de faire du
cinéma aussi je veux chanter toute ma
vie je veux chanter dans toutes les
langues possibles et impossibles je vais
voyager beaucoup j'adore communiquer
avec les gens je veux faire du cinéma
dans l'actualité pour vous c'est un
nouveau 45 tours qui vient de sortir une
nouvelle chanson c'est un virage parce
que c'est quand même un peu différent ce
titre est quand même différent oui c'est
pas nous
on s'est tout simplement quelque chose
que j'avais envie de faire j'avais le
goût de souligner un petit peu plus
j'imaginais encore le goût chanter des
chansons romantiques mais je veux je
veux bouger aussi mais je veux tout me
permettre je veux faire du jazz je veux
faire plein de choses ont écouté cette
chanson vous nous donner le titre
je ne veux pas voilà céline dion merci
et à très bientôt bientôt